i'm going to start with i think the most
important question which is so you just
worked with quentin tarantino you now
played elvis and you're going to be part
of masters of the air
have you thought about playing like the
lottery or doing something because you
know what i mean yeah dogs are clearly
shining
yeah i gotta pinch myself every day it's
just uh
yeah i feel i i it's that thing where i
i can't
believe that this is my life sometimes i
feel so lucky well i mean the thing is
you've been you've been in the business
for a little while this is like your
first
big you know being number one on the
call sheet being the center of attention
what surprised you actually about being
like playing the main role in a movie
like this and being this you know what i
mean yeah yeah i think
i think with this
and this is beyond the film for me like
this is
because it's
it's this
it's
honoring a man's life and and one who
has been so misconstrued
and his life has been so pulled out of
context
um and all his family's gone through and
um and so doing justice to them and and
him
that
was so much pressure
and so
this has taught me a lot about how to
manage that
level of responsibility and the feeling
of
when you have moments of self-doubt what
do you do and and all that kind of stuff
you know i can't imagine what was it
like a lot of again i've spoken to a lot
of actors and they talk about when they
rap on a movie how it takes them a
little while to decompress from the role
on a role like this which is elvis yeah
how long did it take you to find like
austin again
after rapping i'm still still looking um
i um
yeah it was
it was really i mean a solid couple
months before i really felt kind of
some semblance of normal afterward i
i had never
um
i'd never
done something in the way where i i just
completely like i just put my life aside
and it wasn't i didn't see my family i
didn't see my friends i didn't see
anybody for the two years that i was
filming the movie
and uh or working on it and
um so you kind of don't know what to do
with yourself when you finish it's it's
really strange so you you showed this
movie first of all i want to say on
camera how great you are in this movie
thank you blown away by your performance
um
you've shown this movie to a lot of
critic like in festivals it's been
you've been traveling with it but i know
last night maybe was the most nervous
for you showing it to your sister was
that like were you like legit scared to
to have her see it yeah i was
to be honest i was most scared to have
priscilla and lisa mauricio
that that was when i was i was
i was sweating i was like really nervous
because
uh they were they were at the core of
everything for me so
once i knew how they felt about it
that relieved so much of the the stress
that i had felt for so long my sister
was it was more
i was so grateful to get to share with
her the thing that i like i i i told her
you know last night i'm
i'm sorry that i disappeared for two
years you know because it's a it's a
weird thing and uh so i'm learning how
to balance that but um to get to finally
share this thing with her that i
had gone away and disappeared and
done you know it was really special for
me on that note i'm out of time i'm just
going to say a sincere congrats you did
such a great job and i hope it's a huge
hit for you guys
you